I want to talk today about a more sort of
realistic and finely tuned possible roadmap
for starting to reopen the economy, starting
to get people back to work, something that
will get us more in the direction of what
we all felt was kind of normal life up until
a few months ago.
Donald Trump has been making very strong pronouncements
about he gets to decide he has absolute authority
over governors.
He's starting to provide lists of states that
are ready and lists of states that are not.
And those that should do this and those that
should do that.
And it's all happening.
Absent a broader understanding of how the
economic questions relate to the health questions,
relate to testing questions, relate to types
of tests and medical equipment and supplies.
And so I thought we would go through something
that's a little bit more fact-based.
And there's actually a very good roadmap done
by Morgan Stanley, the financial firm.
I know.
But it's a it's actually a great roadmap that
takes into consideration a lot of these different
elements which we will be looking at and a
few important things that we sort of need
to be thinking about that this roadmap does
think about.
One is it considers when are the multiple
peaks of the U.S. likely to be because different
parts of the U.S. are going to peak at different
points in time.
And we believe we may be at the peak or plateau
or just past it nationally, but it is still
very much regionalized.
Number two, it takes into consideration testing
capacity and it also bears in mind the possibility
or likelihood of a second wave of infection.
And this is one of the things that's so important
to understand.
If you're going to talk about people getting
back to work, you have to talk about testing
capacity if you're going to have the conversation
about getting back to work.
You need to be talking about not only the
RNA tests, but also antibody tests and more
testing allows more people to go back to work
in two ways.
Number one, you can figure out who has the
antibodies and therefore is a good candidate
to go back to work.
Number two, you can more quickly figure out
who is sick and you can immediately quarantine
them.
You've got to establish contact tracing.
And you also have to make sure that the people
they've been in touch with are not out in
public.
So a lot of this stuff has to be done together.
The amount of testing that needs to be done
is dramatically higher than what we have the
capacity to do now.
And it is expensive.
But I think at this point, hopefully people
are starting to understand it could cost about
$100 billion a year to
do the testing that we need to do that we
should be doing.
But that's way cheaper than the trillions
that's being required in government stimulus
to try to keep the economy something approximating
afloat.
So one of the things that you see in this
Morgan Stanley roadmap is that by the end
of April, we need to be at the testing capacity
of 500000 tests a day.
Right now, we're at about 20 percent of that.
We're testing about 100 to 150 thousand a
day.
Within the next two weeks.
We need to up that to 500000 tests today by
the end of May.
We need to be at a million test today and
testing capacity.
Now, that's conservative.
I've seen other roadmaps that say we need
22 million tests today because that will let
you test the entire U.S. population every
two weeks on a rolling basis at minimum.
Any serious get back to work plan has to be
testing one million per day by June.
We need what's called serology testing, widely
available.
These are the antibody tests so that you can
identify by June.
It's likely that the real number of people
who who will have had coronavirus in the U.S.
will be in the millions.
You want to be able to identify those people.
And then and if you can do all of these things,
you continue social distancing for a while.
You get your testing capacity to a million
a day and you get antibody testing widely
available in mid-June, what we call Wave 1
could go back to work.
That's the people that were infected early
and potentially some people who are determined
to be at very, very low risk.
Wave two of going back to work would be somewhere
around, according to this plan, July 15.
And then we get to the discussion about schools
and vaccines.
This roadmap says schools could reopen in
mid-September if everything else happens.
And then there could be a potential vaccine
for health care workers in late October.
Now, I know that a lot of people are going
to resist accepting that as a possibility.
We were told, you know, the vaccine will take
a
year to a year and a half.
That is all true.
But we heard from the lead Corona virus vaccine
research person at the National Institute
of Health.
She was on Anderson Cooper's program on Tuesday
night.
She said the way things are going, if things
go well, we don't need a miracle.
We just need to avoid setbacks.
We would likely have a strong enough efficacy
signal from one of the vaccine candidates
where we could start giving it to health care
workers in.
Fall under an emergency use protocol.
The idea being, again, if things go well,
will no setbacks, no miracles.
The vaccine could start to be broadly available
in March of 2021.
So the idea here is let's find a less economically
costly way to save lives.
If you're confident that you are isolating
infected people, those not infected can be
tested for antibodies and sent back, monitored
for symptoms and tested for the virus.
This can be done.
We're not helpless.
We just don't have the resources we need to
do it every day.
Trump is asked about testing and he says testing
is great.
We have the most tests.
We have the best tests.
Now, the best tests is a question mark.
The most tests depends on what you mean.
We certainly are not doing the most testing
per capita testing per capita.
We're right around 30, 50 or 40th in the world.
You have to look at what South Korea was able
to do.
You have to look at what Singapore did, although
they have a bit bit of a different tolerance.
These are examples.
The reemergence risk is very, very big.
And if we don't do something like what the
Morgan Stanley roadmap suggests and again,
this is not Morgan Stanley ideas, this is
just Morgan Stanley hiring doctors and economists
to work on something like this.
What you can what you don't want to do is
start opening areas and causing spikes.
And you're going to have like a whack a mole
opening and shutting.
For the next 18 months, if you do it that
way, that's terrible for lives and it's bad
for the economy.
What we need to do is say the hundred billion
a year at all costs to do the testing we need
to do is cheaper than the stimulus and it's
better for people and it's better for the
economy.
Get the serology antibody testing going, start
returning, wave one to work, wave two to work.
But the testing has to come first.
And as always, every single one of these steps
is if everything goes well.
When you've got people in Michigan, more recently
in Kentucky that are ignoring social distancing
rules, they're going out and protesting.
They're starting the Don't Tread on me type
stuff about restricted civil liberties and
on and on and on.
And there's really no risk here.
And we've got to open things up with no actual
regard for what's going on.
Then none of these roadmaps will work.
The roadmaps assume that everybody plays ball
and that people actually pay attention.
And the unfortunate reality is only part of
the country is doing that.
And so my point here is to say you don't have
to sacrifice the economy in total in order
to preserve health.
What we're missing that lets us do that, though,
and put a plan together that starts to help
the economy
while still keeping people safe as we need
dramatically more testing.
And it's not.
We're talking about going from one hundred
twenty five thousand ish tests a day to at
least a million a day.
That's going 10x our current capacity.
And even better would be to get five million
tests a day, 10 million tests today.
The saliva test may help the Abbott tests.
They're not really helping very much because
you the test takes five to fifteen minutes,
but each machine can only do one test at a
time.
So if they each take five minutes, they can
only do twelve twelve tests an hour.
They take fifteen minutes.
They can only do four tests an hour.
So step testing has to be scaled up and Trump
is pretending everything's fine.
That is a very serious problem and it's become
politicized.
Any question about testing during the press
briefings now is seen as a hostile question
by Trump causing him to just spout the lies
that we have the most and the best tests.
And we're not gonna get anywhere until that
changes.
In the meantime, very quickly, we are starting
to see this battle between Donald Trump and
governors.
I believe the governors have the constitution
on their side.
I believe federalism makes it very clear that
Donald Trump does not have the authority to
force any state to open.
But that is increasingly a battle that that
is going to be fought.
Let me know what you think about this general
roadmap.
This general paradigm for a roadmap to both
keeping people safe, but starting to reopen
elements of the economy.
And do you agree that it only works if everybody
plays ball?
I think that's the most important thing.
And pretending that some states can do nothing
while other states follow a roadmap.
It's not going to work friends.
It's just not going to work.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we have a fantastic Friday program
for you today.
I'm so glad you're joining me.